claude guyot ancien ministre de
l'intérieur de nicolas sarkozy et bon
connaisseur de l'afrique est notre
invité bonsoir monsieur gérant son match
et aussi merci d'être avec nous ce soir
alors que la france est engagée donc
depuis quatre jours maintenant dans une
guerre contre le terrorisme
au mali un tournant dans le quinquennat
de françois hollande de suzette bloch de
l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire et puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindront sur ce plateau il sera
question également bien sûr de l'ump une
nouvelle formule à apaiser ou non et
puis de vous dans votre robe d'avocat
une nouvelle orientation dans votre
carrière
mais d'abord bien sûr les risques
terroristes pour la france est ce qu'il
faut craindre les djihadistes lorsqu il
menace de frapper la france en son coeur
oui les jihadistes ont effectivement ces
dernières heures menacé par communiqué
la france où je dois dire que ce n'est
pas nouveau tout au long des mois et des
années qui viennent de s'écouler
il y a eu des menaces explicites à
l'égard de la france dénoncée comme
étant l'ennemi principal
cela étant sans qu'il faille s'affoler
il est certain qu'il y a relèvement du
niveau de menace et à cet égard il faut
prendre toutes les postures de vigilance
qui sont nécessaires vous pensez que
cette ga liste africains peuvent
susciter des vocations dans notre pays
tout peut arriver il est vrai que
d'abord je pense que nos compatriotes
tous nos établissements qui se situent
en afrique
l'ouest et en afrique centrale se trouve
particulièrement assez nous en avons eu
malheureusement des illustrations dans
le passé notamment avec les prises
d'otages donc pour eux c'est plus facile
d'agir en afrique cela étant les flux de
populations sont incessants entre la
france et l'afrique et ses peuvent aussi
susciter des vocations chez nous envoyer
des commandos ceci dit ce n'est pas si
simple que cela
il faut prendre des mesures de sécurité
générale c'est ce que le gouvernement a
fait en renforçant le niveau du plan
vigipirate
et puis il faut que les services de
renseignement continuent à être
extrêmement attentif à toutes les
menaces même les plus infimes ou à toi
les alertes qui peut se manifester
vous faites confiance en manuel valls
écoutez manuel valls a de très bons
services que j'ai eu l'honneur de
diriger je sais la qualité de ses
services
parce que je pensais que vous parliez
des services de manuel valls lui-même
c'est bon c'est un service à lui des
services de police et de renseignement
vous avez parlé des otages effectivement
il ya encore sept qui sont détenus au
niger
est-ce qu'ils sont mondiaux où ils sont
détenus sans véritablement en or mais ce
que je peux dire pour les sacrifie mais
ce qui est on les oublie au nom de la
raison d'état
le gouvernement a répondu une situation
d'urgence
il est clair que les colotis la miss
prenait le chemin de bamako il était
tout à fait in envisageable que la
capitale du mali qui fait plus de deux
millions d'habitants tombe entre les
mains des islamistes
avec tout ce que ça comporte comme
conséquences des lois de la charia les
maclan couplé à l'interdiction de fumer
l'obligation pour les femmes de se
voiler etc etc
d'autre part s'il allait jusque là
c'était le début d'une tâche d'huile qui
pouvaient s'étendre à toute la région et
c'était la fin d'un régime démocratique
au mali alors que le mali a longtemps
été un exemple donc il fallait faire
quelque chose c'est tout à fait
évident mais les auteurs mais les otages
en les exploitant des otages je pense
que évidemment 90 officiellement y pense
je crois pour ma part que là le risque
pour les otages ne s'est pas aggravée
alors évidemment nos adversaires
islamistes ne sont pas forcément
complètement rationnelle mais ils
peuvent être tentés par des coups
médiatiques indiquant à la france en
particulier à l'occident en général qui
sont les maîtres de la situation qu'ils
font ce qu'ils veulent et c est ça
pourrait être dangereux pour les otages
les sites sont rationnels il doit bien
se rendre compte aussi que le prix des
otages a augmenté et que par conséquent
il est très important de les garder en
vie
d'accord françois hollande a été
explicite bien sûr celle sur les
objectifs de cette intervention
militaire française
vous l'avez dit stopper la montée des
colonnes jihadiste sur bamako préserver
la capitale malienne est ce que vous
vous avez des questions à poser à
l'exécutif sur les objectifs poursuivis
dans son objectif me semble clair et
stable sur le plan militaire
sûr que je voudrais ajouter c'est que il
faut aussi introduire une dimension
politique dans le règlement de ce
problème
n'oublions pas que le mali depuis le
coup d'état qui a mené le départ de mme
annie toumani touré
et sous un régime qui n'a pas de
légitimité
ce n'est pas normal et on ne peut pas
avoir des institutions fortes
on ne peut pas avoir un état fort on ne
peut pas avoir une armée disciplinée
organisé et forte s'il n'y a pas un état
légitime c'est pas la plongée le pascal
r je n'ai pas la france bien sûr mais
dès lors que la france prenne un
concours qui est tout à fait
considérable d'autant plus considérable
que 1 il est puissant 2 il est pour
l'instant tout à fait solidaire il est
normal que la france disent aussi son
point de vue là dessus ça me semble tout
à fait nécessaire de la même façon que
nous savons que dans la naissance de ce
conflit et dans l'implantation des
terroristes dans le nord du mali
il y a une comment dire complaisance de
la part du monde touareg du nord du mali
et 6 lits à cette complaisance cette
familiarité qui s'est créé au fil des
années entre le monde touareg du
nord-mali et les terroristes
ça veut dire qu'il y avait un malaise au
sein de l'état malien entre le pouvoir
central et les touareg et là aussi je
crois qu'il faudra apporter des
solutions qui ne me semble pas
d'ailleurs hors de portée enfin il ya
beaucoup de pays qui sont confrontés à
des identités très particulière et qui
savent leur donner leur place dans le
respect de l'unité nationale or vous
avez souligné la solitude de la france
actuelle 1 en attendant le juridique
pour l'instant été seulement est seul
pour l'instant sauver des sur un plan
logistique par les britanniques par les
canadiens qui a joué normales et
transparentes les parisiens mais pour
l'instant effectivement au jeu ou bien à
la tête aux commandes d'avions de chasse
de bombardements il n'y a que des
français alors la france
tél raison de se démentir en quelque
sorte puisque françois hollande avait
dit que la france ne livrait pas la
bataille seule et qu'elle viendrait
justement en appui logistique d'une
force je crois qu'ils vont ou
reconnaître de plusieurs choses l'abord
l'urgence dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
il fallait aller vite et seule la france
était en mesure de réagir rapidement
parce qu'elle a depuis longtemps déjà
des troupes dans la région
la fois des troupes de l'armée de l'air
n'est troupes terrestres
elle avait la capacité de réagir ce que
personne d'autre ne pouvait faire il
faut bien voir aussi que la france
intervient sous mandat des nations unies
d'autre part dernière chose à laquelle
il faut prêter attention parce que c'est
très profond dans la relation que nous
pouvons avoir avec l'afrique
le la france est intervenue à la demande
de l'état malien
il a beau être pas très légitime il
n'empêche qu'il représente aujourd'hui
le pays
donc la france à l'horizon d'intervenir
nous savons par ailleurs et le premier
ministre a dit tout à l'heure que ce
serait fait dans une semaine que les
pays africains de la région ont prévu de
concentrer 3300 homme qui pourrait aider
l'armée malienne
mais vous savez dans cette affaire je
crois qu'il faut aussi savoir ce que
l'on veut je crois que quand on fait la
guerre
on l'a fait vraiment on la fait pas à
moitié et je crois à cet égard que le
gouvernement lui était bien inspiré de
nous dire tout de suite d'ailleurs quels
étaient les bulles enfin je me souviens
en fin de semaine dernière le
gouvernement nous disait encore que les
troupes françaises n'interviendrait
qu'en appui les troupes maliennes et
n'interviendra pas au sol alors que de
bamako nous montrait des images de
blindés qui était en train de se
préparer les blindés c'est pas en l'air
justement de la guerre au sol elle est
indispensable face aux combattants et
mondialiste hungry connaissait bien le
désert leur territoire qui peuvent y
rouler digne c'est vrai les yeux fermés
même la nuit
ça je ne sais pas mais ce sont des bons
combattants qui sont très déterminés qui
sont très armés puissent possible ils se
sont servis dans les arsenaux du colonel
kadhafi un certain nombre d'entre eux
d'ailleurs étaient des mercenaires
déconnecté d'affi il avant trop payé et
il rentre au pays avec leur armement
par ailleurs les troubles islamistes
seront beaucoup plus augmenté enfin je
me souviens que quand j'étais auprès de
nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée on disait que
ses troupes étaient de l'ordre de cinq
ou six cents personnes
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'accorde à
dire qu'elles sont entre 2500 et 3000
combattants ce qui en fait
élément redoutable est ce que mes mails
ce qu'il faut de toute façon c'est aussi
tenir compte du terrain je le disais
tout à l'heure au fil du temps les
islamistes sont devenus familiers du
désert et sont devenus familiers des
habitants du désert
bon ça veut dire qu'ils vivent avec eux
et on a bien vu hier qu'ils cherchaient
à occuper un village pour se mêler à la
population et gêner ou empêcher
l'intervention française et c'est vrai
que nous n'allons pas aller bombarder
dévidage au risque de tuer ou de blesser
des populations civiles
donc c'est chou ce genre de choses ça ne
se traitent qu'à terre alors vous allez
c'était la libye est ce que la france
avec d'autres pays d'ailleurs n'a pas
contribué bien armer nos ennemis
d'aujourd'hui avec ses armes qu'ils
reviennent de n'être toujours refaire
l'histoire je rappellerai simplement la
raison de l'intervention française et
britannique en libye
cette intervention est intervenue
quelques heures seulement avant que la
ville de benghazi qui est une très
grande ville soit noyée dans le sang
bien sûr mais aujourd'hui
malheureusement il ya seize armes qui
reviennent et qui sont retournés contre
nous oui c'est vrai il y avait aussi des
armes qu'ils viennent d'ailleurs vous
savez oui alors vous avez dit que
l'important c'était notamment de
restaurer l'autorité politique à bamako
à françois hollande déclare à dubaï que
la france n'a pas vocation à rester au
mali vous approuvez bien sûr également
cette déclaration du chef de l'état bah
oui c'est clair le mali c'est le mali
s'est tenue en la guerre peut durer on
est dans cet engrenage qui se passe est
très difficile de le dire et c'est pour
ça que je dis il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut vraiment si on l'a fait il faut la
faire
oui vraiment parce que si on ne fait pas
vraiment ça peut durer très très
longtemps et plus on l'a fait vraiment
moi ça dure mais ça dure quand même
quelques semaines voire quelques mois
est ce que l'unité nationale et le
soutien de l'opinion publique
suivront également écouter pour ma part
je l'espère bon il fonce sur le premier
prince l'erythrée nationale hier ça
n'est pas dangereux c'est ce n'est pas
une guerre c'est dangereux c'est pas
sans risque une guerre et nous avons
malheureusement je crois que la
cérémonie a eu lieu aujourd'hui même en
l'honneur de sa mémoire
un pilote d'hélicoptère qui a été tué
parce qu'il a reçu une balle dans une
artère bon malheureusement je crains
qu'il y ait d'autres morts mais cela
étant l'enjeu est important parce que je
me disais déjà tout à l'heure si nous
n'arrivons pas à stopper cette
affaire-là le nous étant très collectif
ne concerne pas que la france
ça concerne tous les pays de cette
région et ça concerne le royaume-uni les
etats-unis ça concerne tout le monde qui
est l'objet de la haine des islamistes
si nous n'y arrivons pas eh bien nous
nous risquons d'avoir une sorte de gros
aghanistan dans une région avec laquelle
nous avons des liens très forts très
particulier qui ne sont pas seulement
politique mais très affective parce que
on parle du mali il ya énormément de
maliens qui vivent en france et qui
deviennent des français souvent donc et
nous ne pouvons pas tolérer cela il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
est ce que le débat politique où les
guéguerres politiciennes au tour des
autres sujets d'actualité dans tous les
domaines économiques nature quand des
militaires français sont engagés à
l'extérieur risquent leur vie au nom de
l'agent je dirais qu'il faut bien
séparer les
11 et il y à unité nationale et je m'en
réjouis comme je crois tous les
responsables politiques autour de cette
intervention au mali mais il y à
d'autres sujets qui caractérise la vie
politique de notre pays mérite je vais
et je pars les invectives les critiques
ou les propositions je crois que l'unité
qui se fait autour de l'intervention au
mali ne doit pas donner au gouvernement
et au président de la république ce
sentiment qui peut faire n'importe quoi
très bien en tous les cas on le voit
aujourd'hui trois faits semblent se
conjuguer pour accréditer l'idée d'un
virage dans le quinquennat donc on en a
longuement parlé bien sûr la guerre au
mali l'accord sur la flexibilité qui a
été obtenu à 20khz été réclamée en tous
les cas pas par le chef de l'état et
puis également son inflexibilité sur le
mariage gay le gouvernement est bien
resté impassible malgré la mobilisation
de dimanche ses opposants
au château on guette un rebond dans les
sondages on va pouvoir en parler dans un
instant avec le sujet de blocs de l'
agence france-presse qui vous
interrogera également sur la situation à
l'ump est d'abord donc le point sur son
rebond politique et son âge est attendue
à l'elysée avec la bri qui n'avaient
ensuite vous réagirez monsieur guerre
d'accord il a son accord sa manif et sa
guerre ces mots sont ceux d'un
conseiller de l'elysée d'abord l'accord
sur le marché du travail trouvé vendredi
valider la méthode du chef de l'état qui
s'était personnellement impliqué pour
que ces négociations aboutissent
je sais que les partenaires sociaux je
leur fais confiance saisiront cette
occasion
face à la mobilisation contre le mariage
pour tous sans suite
l'elysée est resté ferme quitte à
s'attirer les foudres de l'opposition
vouloir imposer d'un comme le fait
monsieur hollande un projet sans aucun
véritable complètement l'organisation
familles en france ça n'est vraiment pas
le moment et il ya bien sûr
l'intervention au mali françois hollande
endosse cette fois le costume de chef
des armées
cette opération confirme la
détermination de la france à ne pas
céder au chantage des terroristes
la séquence de ces derniers jours a
animé la réunion du groupe socialiste au
sénat ce matin ici pas de doute le
quinquennat vient de vivre un tournant
le président a changé de dimension il
est dans le costume d'un président de la
république qui assume ses
responsabilités et qui prend des
décisions courageuses
qui sont importantes au moment où il le
faut à droite on reste beaucoup plus
mesurée mais la fermeté affichée sur
trois tableaux par françois hollande a
visiblement surpris ont conseillé que
vous avez été validé à cette séquence
pour le président long oui mais nous
chercher toujours les issues et donc là
c'est c'est pas tout à fait fini encore
mais cela dit bon on peut dire ayez un
plus comme note
une chose est sûre les suites de ce
week-end sur tous les fronts restent
très incertaines pour l'elysée où l'on
attendra les prochains sondages avant de
tirer un premier bilan
les trois événements pratiquement
simultanées ont certainement renforcé la
stature présidentielle du chef de l'état
il n'est pas du tout évident que les
trois événements contribuer durablement
à sa popularité
si on les prend un par un on s'aperçoit
qu'ils sont très ambivalents
en clair les trois événements du
week-end peuvent apparaître comme
providentiel pour un président en mal de
reconnaissance
encore faudra-t-il en maîtriser les
effets politiques à long terme
voilà six blocs de l' agence
france-presse
ce nous a rejoint claude guéant bonsoir
fait cette question avec l'oignon
d'abord bien sûr sûr sûr la nouvelle
posture de nouveaux galons françois
hollande alors françois hollande a gagné
ses galons de chef d'état en affichant
une telle résolution
willy de ninon crier aussi en a plus
monsieur des eaux
tout dépend de son dont on parle parce
qu on a parlé de trois sujets à
l'instant et je voudrais dire une
première chose par rapport aux sujets
qui nous venons de voir c'est que
l'objectif d'un chef d'état est
l'objectif d'un gouvernement ce n'est
pas de gagner des points dans les
sondages c'est de traiter les problèmes
de la france
alors en l'espèce nous avons une
unanimité nationale autour du président
de la république et le gouvernement à
propos de l'intervention omani ça c'est
un point
nous avons ensuite quelque chose
d'important qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière c'est à dire l'élaboration d'un
projet c'est encore un projet puisque
les organisations syndicales sont
appelés à se prononcer formellement à
son sujet
sur le marché du travail le parlement le
parlement d'abord les organes joutes
locales et le parlement ensuite aussi ou
et qui peut être sera tenté d'apporter
des innovations qui vont au delà où sont
différentes de ce que les partenaires
sociaux ont de même apporté pardon ce
sont des bons points attendez j'ai pas
tout dit madame je dois vieux mais je
disais que c'était non j'ai pas très
belle deuxième j'ai simplement décrit ce
qui s'était passé
bon il ya des choses positives dans cet
accord c'est incontestable le fait que
les salariés tous les salariés voient la
perspective d'une mutuelle
complémentaire santé c'est quelque chose
de très bien
le fait que l'on donne un peu de
souplesse aux entreprises lorsqu'elles
sont en difficulté c'est très bien aussi
ce que je voudrais dire cependant ces
deux choses à propos de ce qui s'est
passé
la première chose c'est que le contrat
de maintien dans l'emploi qui est un
point fort de ce document qui a été
signé par les partenaires
ça n'est ni plus ni moins que le contrat
emploi compétitivité du gouvernement
précédent et je dirai ce que vous n'avez
s'il ne comprend pas coté dit et ça
c'est fait et je voudrais dire aussi
quelque chose a besoin qu'ils ont formés
ne s'est pas indifférent c'est que une
négociation avait été lancée sur tous
ces sujets qui lors du sommet social qui
s'est tenu à la rentrée a été
brutalement interrompue par le
gouvernement qui a dit on arrête ça et
on va recommencer la même chose mais
avec mes couleurs
ça c'est un point et puis sur cet accord
qui est intervenu c'est vrai qu'il ya
des choses positives
globalement ça va dans le bon sens mais
il y a tellement à faire encore un droit
du travail tellement compliqué il a mon
seuil ayant échoué dans la continuité en
fait vous parler de continuité mais oui
bcge aux autres couleurs mais je veux
restituer la vérité des choses si vous
voulez on n'est pas passés avec le
monsieur hollande et gouvernement
socialiste de l'ombre à la lumière
il ya bien des choses qui avait été
entamé et ce que je regrette beaucoup
c'est que jamais on ne reconnaissent le
bien de ce qui s'est fait quelques
foyers d exception monsieur moscovici
rentrant de chine l'autre jour a dit
nous avons ans j'ai entendu de mes
oreilles à la radio 1 nous avons en
france quelque chose de formidable c'est
le comment ça s'appelle le impôt
recherche crédit impôt recherche le
crédit impôt recherche
ces quelques chaînes effectué tout le
monde entier nous envie et c'est la
première fois que j'entendais sans
peut-être qu'ils en prennent
immédiatement conscience un moment du
gouvernement rendre un hommage vibrant à
nicolas sarkozy ce qui est ce que c'est
ce que françois hollande vous a surpris
non enfin moi je pouvais savez la
fonction toute la fonction paiement sur
notre lame et à françoise françois
hollande est quelqu'un de très estimable
très respectable il est cultivé
intelligent il connaît les affaires
publiques c'était dans des entités
personne et personne n'a décision bah
écoutez c'est ce qu'on remarque
effectivement dans vos coups de coeur de
l'action publique mais la salle écouté
il a pris une décision qui était
salutaire et vous savez un président qui
est confrontée une action comme une
situation comme celle-là prend la
décision c'est sa fonction
et puis il ya un troisième sujet c'est
l'inflexibilité à l'égard de la réaction
tout à fait considérable qui s'est
manifestée dimanche dernier contre le
projet dit de mariage pour tous et bien
là je trouve que ce n'est pas bien que
le président de la république et le
gouvernement fasse comme si rien ne
s'était passé il y a eu un mouvement
d'opinion considérable et tout cela est
traité par le mépris comme s'il peut
rien ne s'était passé ce qu'il faut que
j'attende ans à la manifestation des
gens favorables au mariage gay ils vont
arriver dans la rue en otage tout je
remarque c'est que à notre dame des
landes
il ya eu quelques dizaines de
manifestants on a arrêté un processus on
a ouvert en concertation
la concertation c'est le mot d'ordre
c'est la méthode comme vous disiez tout
à l'heure qui est prônée par le
gouvernement
là il ya un trouble de conscience
formidable dans ce pays est grosso modo
on peut dire que sur le mariage lui-même
est à peu près une moitié moitié et sans
compter sans compter sans compter sans
compter qu'il n'ya pas que ça parce
qu'on a dit le gouvernement est souple
et flexible il lâche du lest et cetera
à propos de la procréation médicale
assistée s'agissant des couples
homosexuels femmes
puisque le projet d'inscrire cette
disposition est annoncée pour deux mois
après alors qu'on arrête de nous faire
prendre des vessies pour des lanternes
et au nom du principe d'égalité qui sous
tend tout cela ça veut dire qu'on a là
on aura la gestation pour autrui pour
les couples homosexuels hommes bien moi
je trouve que c'est pas ce n'est pas
acceptable
enfin c'est mon opinion mais beaucoup de
français la partage et même sur pma et
gpa
c'est une grande majorité de français
c'est au tour des trois quarts parce que
l'enfant ne peut pas être un objet et le
ventre de la femme n'est pas à vendre
voilà vous réquérir décoincer la madame
taubira nous dit c'est un changement de
civilisation et c'est vrai que de toute
façon depuis la nuit des temps
la société est structurée autour de la
famille je ne comptais sans aucune façon
la légitimité des de la majorité
présidentielle au sénat comme à
l'assemblée nationale
mais ceci dit quand on change de
civilisation ce n'est pas une majorité
légitime qui suffit c'est au peuple de
se prononcer donc un point négatif de
points positifs en plus en plus dans
tous les cas non un point négatif
un point positif et un point d'équilibré
alors on va faire la moyenne sur
l'accord social borloo applaudi vous
jugez que cela va dans la bonne
direction parce qu'il faisait pas
suffisamment mais dont vous croyez bien
que finalement la présidente du medef
alors qu'elle est contente mais c'est
sont d'accord parce qu'elle méritait de
rester à la tête du medef elle veut là
elle veut c'est charmant gorille des
fois j'y connais rien du tout dans la
peau du leader
mais parfois je suis plus critique que
laurence parisot par exemple laurence
parisot a dit que c'était formidable que
d'avoir l'accord sur la compétitivité
la décision sur la compétitivité qui a
été prise et elle salue avec
enthousiasme le fait que nous allons
avoir un crédit d'impôt compétitivité
qui va réduire à terme de 20 milliards
et charges sur les entreprises
moi je suis plus sévère que ça parce que
je dis que cette année il ya 17
milliards d'impôts en plus sur les
entreprises et on fait miroiter moins 20
milliards dans trois ans bon écoutez
franchement c'est 0-1 hausse à rien
strictement même rien n'a été fait on me
suit guirons change un peu de sujet
c'est une autre ton est un peu limité
heureusement alors l'ump réconcilier le
groupe dissident de l'assemblée lors on
peut dit sous une direction paritaire
copéiste fillonniste monsieur guéant
c'est l'entente cordiale où la paire
mais ce qui compte et c'est très
important c'est que les protagonistes et
l'ump dans sa globalité et réussi à
trouver un mode de fonctionnement
jusqu'à la nouvelle élection qui aura
lieu au mois de septembre prochain qui
permet à l'ump de rester combative une
vraie force de propositions par rapport
à l'opinion et c'est ça qui compte c'est
quand même un peu bizarre quoi il ya une
direction transitoire avec une armée
mexicaine et un doublement des postes
commence à faire beaucoup
est-ce que ça risque pas de paralyser
fonctionnement de ne lui et je ne crois
pas du tout vous savez il y a eu un
affrontement entre des hommes qui
étaient l'un et l'autre candidat à la
présidence de l'ump
cela étant quand vous lisez les discours
quand vous avez entendu les discours de
l'un et de l'autre vous
pour qui est vrai comme le défi
trouverez cette occasion n'y a pas de
problème de ligne politique est un
problème d'homme il n'y a pas de
politique et une deux entre les hommes
mais ceux qui se sont retrouvés dans un
camp et dans l'autre en situation de se
combattre finalement pour assurer le
triomphe de leur champion était
auparavant de très bons amis
élaboré en l'ensemble des programmes
avant durant deux saisons que je pense
que nous aurons vraiment maintenant la
possibilité de reprendre ce qui le
travail de l'humanité c'est-à-dire de
proposer une alternative hawks qui sont
toujours crédibles ils ont des fils et
dans les semaines à geler française
encore une fois c'est pas les sondages
vont essayer exprime quelque chose les
sondages veut pas dire que sa valeur à
temps plein oui mais c'est vrai mais ça
vous parlez des chefs des chefs qui
concerne le mouvement
je crois que dans les semaines qui
viennent nous aurons la démonstration
que l'ump est capable un de critiquer le
gouvernement lorsqu'il ya matière à
critique et deux de proposer aux
français une alternative sur toutes ces
questions de compétitivité ou de droit
du travail
bon il ya des différences considérables
à ce gouvernement et l'ump dans son
ensemble et je crois qu'en matière de
grâce mais qui est en train de se
constituer à l'horizon
ils se constituent ça veut dire qu'un
seppi chacun joue sa créance qui compte
c'est que l'ump soit un mouvement
capable de commencer à refaire sa base
doctrinale parce qu'il faut toujours
l'actualiser le monde va tellement vite
et qui soit capable de s'opposer au
gouvernement quand c'est nécessaire et
de dire aux français qu'il ya d'autres
choses à faire
parce que actuellement le gouvernement
ne prend pas le bon chemin alors dans le
domaine économique nous avons tous une
obsession c'est l'emploi
on l'emploie c'est pas avec des contrats
d'avenir ou bien des emplois d'avenir ou
des contrats de génération qu'on va le
régler ça arrive provisoirement des
situations individuelles et c'est bien
ok mais cela étant pour régler les
problèmes de l'emploi il faut que les
entreprises soient incités à investir il
faut que les consommateurs aient les
moyens consommer votre déjeuner pas fait
votre discours monsieur guéant move on a
vu là le nouvel organigramme de l'ump je
n'ai pas vu votre nom comment comment
allez vous l'appliquez politiquement
quel est votre avenir politique comment
le voyez-vous coûté mon avenir politique
a peu d'intérêt
mais voyez vous m'avez invité je dis ce
que je pense est ce que je pensais
d'ailleurs cohérent avec ce que pense
l'ump
enfin c'est mais alors on ne mange pas
une certaine liberté de ton parfois on a
parlé de la guerre des chefs avec une
image écornée pour le moins de françois
fillon et jean françois copé est ce que
selon vous cela installe encore plus et
bien la position de nicolas sarkozy
comme un éventuel recours
je ne parle pas d'un retour mais un
recours de jeu je ne fais pas d analyse
de la situation
ce que je veux dire pour ma part c'est
que je souhaite c'est pas nouveau j'ai
déjà dit que nicolas sarkozy revienne
dans le jeu politique
est-ce que les circonstances s'y
prêteront je ne sais pas est ce qu'il le
voudra je ne sais pas mais je dis qu'il
a été un formidable président de la
république et monsieur nouveau moscovici
lui même lui trouve aujourd'hui des
vertus et longues années jusqu'à jusqu'à
la cité mais enfin quand même il a cité
le crédit d'impôt recherche est
formidable alors que l'aca peut
témoigner c'est son idée à lui
personnellement c'est son visage est
passablement d'encre et ils reviendront
la même façon que n'oublions pas vous
savez on
on fasse vite sur les faits le monde et
l'actualité vont tellement vite et mais
en 2008 il a quand même sauvé les
équilibres financiers de l'europe et par
conséquent pendant votre voeu avec vos
doigts j'espère qu'un jour il reviendra
votre voeu il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à faire en france c'est votre
2013 et les années qui viennent
qu'il revienne oui bien sûr l'euro 2013
ça me semble trop trop délinquants mais
j'en sais rien mais qu'il revienne un
jour et jésus berges et lumière et 7
mois j'espère de tout coeur qu'il
prendra à nouveau la responsabilité de
la france parce qu'il ya énormément de
choses à flot je vais vous dire une
chose
j'ai plus de liberté le temps j'ai plus
de temps je voyage un peu je vois plus
de monde venant d'horizons différents
notre pays a décroché un point que je
n'imaginais pas et peu à peu on
s'assoupit dans la torpeur on est en
train de glisser sur une pente tout fait
nous amène un vrai déclare il faut
reprendre les choses en main dès le
retour ne retourne seul monsieur sarkozy
vous pensez et en abap abap ce dont je
suis sûre je sais pas s'il est seul et
son ton jeu sûr qu'il est capable il est
capable mais il va pas se présenter aux
primaires à l'ump pour se représenter en
vous verrez ça parce que non mais ça
serait quoi le schéma bah ouais je sais
rien on verra on verra je vous dis j'ai
dit mon espoir
ensuite il respectera les procédures
c'est qu'on sait quelle serait la
meilleure forme pour lui sans perdre des
plumes dans cette crise l'ump
il s'en était pas mêlé à peine il a
juste dit qu'il fallait trouver une
solution il a bien fait c'était l'espoir
de tout peuple de droite
vous pensez qu'il faut qu'il continuait
à se taire ou s'il ya des petites choses
qui sont bien de temps en temps l'été
dernier il est intervenu sur la syrie
par un communiqué salue et parfois été
reproché
je pense que c'était bien de le faire
sur le mail j'en sais rien mais ça
rappelait que dans une situation de
crise aiguë en 2008 c'était en géorgie
bon il avait interrompu ses vacances et
il avait fait la navette entre toutes
les capitales où il y avait quelque
chose à dire et à faire
merci 7 voilà informés donc sur les
voeux de fautes dures pour l'année
au delà de 2013 où la cuadrilla trajet
pour les années qui viennent vous avez
rien de figé
perrine tarneaud va arriver désormais
pour parler de vous claude guéant
puisque vous êtes avocat désormais après
avoir été d'abord abu dhabi 3 carrière
aux fonctionnaires hommes politiques
voulaient toujours ministre aujourd'hui
avocat on en parle avec erin mais
d'abord cette enquête qu'à tenter de
mener sur vos nouvelles activités
alexandra gobineau après son échec
électoral aux législatives à boulogne
billancourt celui que l'on surnomme le
cardinal porte désormais la robe
d'avocat claude guéant a prêté serment
le 19 décembre au tribunal de paris
mais l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
n'aime pas parler de ces nouvelles
affaires
ils n'autorisent d'ailleurs aucune
visite de journalistes dans son tout
nouveau cabinet d'avocats ouvert avec
son fils françois près des champs
elysées
aucune plaque n'est encore posée tout
juste sait-on qu'il se spécialise en
conseil stratégique en octobre quelques
semaines avant de prêter serment
claude guéant était déjà sur le terrain
une visite au président de guinée
équatoriale pour le compte d'un
entrepreneur français à la déroute
car claude guéant garde un important
carnet d adresses auprès des dirigeants
africains
son ami robert bourgi très proche
conseiller sur les questions africaines
durant le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
confirme l'attachement de l'ancien
conseiller du président à l'afrique
il me fait l'amitié de de me convier la
plupart de ces entretiens même
aujourd'hui avec les chefs et les
dirigeants politiques africains chefs
d'état ou ministre il a gardé de très
bonnes relations avec tout le monde d'un
homme extrêmement respectée même si
n'est plus aux affaires
on la parente à la france afrique c'est
la françafrique ça une tonalité obscures
mais je cherche en vain le nom de
monsieur guéant social angolagate le nom
de gay associé à l'affairé elf
robert bourgi a cependant refusé de
faire partie du voyage en guinée
équatoriale
car le dossier des biens mal acquis a
plus que refroidi les relations entre la
france et la guinée
le club
vous incarnez la probité latérite et des
valeurs des principes avoir des années
il a fait la leçon à tout le monde et
aujourd'hui se ruent pour faire des
affaires et sans doute a fait re
généreusement rémunérés avec un état
dont le principal représentant est
soupçonné de pillage des ressources
publiques de son pays avec un état où
notre eason les dissidents et les
opposants est ce que c'est une belle
manière d'incarner la profession
d'avocat je ne crois pas beaucoup
d'exemples où d'anciens hommes
politiques sont venus chercher cette
espèce de talisman cette espèce de
passeports de vertus qu'offre la robe
noire pour faire des affaires plus
l'autorité de son ancien statut plus son
canada dresser les relations comme à
nous ici ou là et qui donne l'impression
que c'est plutôt le cynisme qui guident
ce type de démarche qu'un véritable
amour pour leur profession l'entourage
de claude guéant affirme que ce dernier
n'a pas bénéficié de passerelle pour
obtenir son nouveau statut d'avocat
il a d'ailleurs été reçu avec une note
de 18 sur 20 à l'oral de déontologie
alors votre réponse à william bourdon
qui vous accusent de faire des affaires
avec la centrafrique et de ne pas faire
honneur à la robe d'avocat écoutez
d'abord je lui dirai que ce que j'ai
fait c'était avant d'être avocat ensuite
avant que la même chez vous apprêtiez à
être un g oui tout à fait j'ai
accompagné une entreprise française en
guinée équatoriale qui était en très
grande difficulté après de premiers
contacts qu'elle avait nouée elle même
quelques mois plus tôt pour tenter de la
sauver
malheureusement ça n'a pas marché
d'ailleurs et pour répondre à ces
accusations qui sont peu confraternel je
lui dirai que je n'ai pas gagné un sou
dans cette affaire j'ai même été de ma
poche
william bourdon qui dit qu'il faut une
bonne dose de cynisme pour aller faire
des affaires en afrique c'est un je n'ai
pas fait d'affaires en afrique
vous êtes un facilitateur d'affaires on
peut dire non mais on l'espèce je vous
dis que la ferrara thé et je le regrette
j'aurais préféré qu'elle réussisse pour
sauver plusieurs centaines d'emplois et
favoriser la création de quelques autres
centaines et deuxièmement je n'ai pas
gagné d'argent du tout pas un centime
j'ai même été un peu de ma porsche
ajouté l'afrique ce sera votre théâtre
d'intervention location coûte et désolé
quelqu'un de 10l à votre journaliste
présentant le sujet disait que je ne
souhaitais pas de visite de mon cabinet
c'est tout simplement parce que la
déontologie de l'avocat interdit qu'il
fasse de la publicité
alors je préfère la publicité à la
télévision quand même donc il ya
beaucoup d'avocats qui reçoit les
journalistes quand même dans leurs
bureaux et comment vous définissez
d'iliad et quelques affaires qui
viennent trop peu à mon regret
d'ailleurs je vous le dis très très
sincèrement voilà c'est difficile la
reconversion du public vers le privé ne
sais pas du tout pareil c'est enfin
c'est une expérience qui tout à fait
différente moi j'ai été habitués pendant
très longtemps pendant toute ma vie
professionnelle sous diverses casquettes
à traiter de sujets généraux et de façon
complètement désintéressé quand vous
êtes fonctionnaire au ministre vous avez
un salaire etc
quand vous êtes avocat vous avez une
entreprise il ya des frais il faut payer
les frais donc il faut assurer un
certain chiffre d'affaires et je
découvre sur le tard ce que c'est que
d'être chef d'entreprise du rhône dit
que c'est dur c'est pas facile du tout
même en termes de procédure je veux dire
qu'avec d'autres j'ai pendant des années
dit c'était année après année surtout
les gouvernants doivent nous disons
facilite la vie des entreprises la
création maintenant il suffit d'un
claquement de doigts c'est fait c'est
pas ça du tout vous savez moi j'ai
entamé les démarches et mon entreprise
n'existe pas encore à ce jour
juridiquement j'ai entamé des démarches
au mois de juillet dernier je vous ai
vus on vous avez sourire lorsque votre
note en matière de déontologie a été
rappelé oui j'ai écouté je suppose que
je le méritais simplement j'ai j'ai
travaillé la matière est ce que un jour
vous aurez envie de raconter votre
parcours politique
écrire vos mémoires je suis partagé
parce que j'ai envie et puis en même
temps écrire c'est très très difficile
c'est vraiment d'un niveau d'exigence
incroyable j'ai déjà expérimenté et est
ce que j'aurai le courage de le faire
j'en sais rien il ya des gens qui va
vous aider à écrire beaucoup d'hommes
politiques les utilisent
j'ai déjà écrit dans un passé presque
deux cents pages et je sais que c'était
la fois agréable et très difficile il
faut s'astreindre à se mettre à sa table
de travail
et puis on se donnait quatre heures 5
heures pour faire vraiment quelque chose
de consistant et de réfléchi stream
sorte d'inventaire des années vous avez
passé aux côtés de nicolas sarkozy
j'espère que ce serait plus qu'un
inventaire mais plutôt les leçons que
pour ma part j'ai tiré de l'expérience
public
mais quelle leçon et non mais c'est pas
le point fort les points faibles c'est
que effectivement quand vous êtes en
responsabilité d'affaires publiques
comme préfet comme je l'entends été avec
beaucoup de frustration parce que vous
apercevez que beaucoup de décisions qui
devraient être prises ne sont pas prises
ce sont des décisions qui sont prises
dans moi vous êtes la fonctionnaire
discipliné vous appliquez cerati crime
ça c'est un premier point
et puis ensuite quand on a la chance
d'être membre du gouvernement ou bien
skatar général de la présidence de la
république donc au centre de beaucoup de
choses on en tire forcément des
conclusions qui sont des conclusions
vigoureuse pour l'action publique
je crois que trop souvent nous avons des
décisions qui sont un peu des compromis
qui ne vont pas jusqu'au bout de la
pensée on savait pas dire que les choses
soient faciles
il est toujours très important pour les
décideurs publics de savoir ne pas aller
trop loin il faut savoir aussi faire
l'analyse de ce qui est acceptable par
la société française ce qui peut passer
ou ne peut pas passer mais je le répète
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
difficile
je le dis je ne pense pas être sans
lucidité en le disant il faut des
décisions courageuses et il faut des
décisions vigoureuses pas facile à
prendre ni à faire accepter
est ce ce que je voudrais dire on est
dans une société de défiance notamment
vis-à-vis des politiques une société de
défiance assez forte et une enquête
encore aujourd'hui du cevipof qui
montrent que les français n'ont plus
aucune confiance dans les politiques
comment vous expliquez ça ça s'explique
assez facilement par la conjoncture si
vous voulez parce que malheureusement il
ya la crise il ya la crise et les
français ont toujours tendance à
attendre de leurs dirigeants tout ce qui
est possible
ils ont l'impression que leurs
dirigeants ne sont pas à la hauteur de
la crise contrairement à ce que monsieur
hollande est parti socialiste avait dit
pendant la campagne présidentielle
malheureusement nous dépendons beaucoup
ne ce qui se passe ailleurs
si la conjoncture est bonne aux états
unis en allemagne et en chine
ça va mieux pour nous que si c'est le
contraire ça a été tout ces temps
derniers le contraire alors ça c'est un
élément de défiance et puis il sent bien
aussi qu'on va rentrer trop souvent des
histoires
en ce moment on sen sujet qui me semble
particulièrement important le
gouvernement a redit sa volonté de
réduire les dépenses publiques
c'est un impératif absolu il se trouve
que la france dépense en dépenses
publiques 200 milliards de plus que
l'allemagne qui pourtant une population
plus importante que je sache il ya un
système de santé un système social en
allemagne qui sont tout à fait
convenable les enfants vont à l'école on
ramasse les ordures dans les rues
donc il ya un problème de bonne
utilisation des deniers publics
et qu'est ce qui a été fait et bien rien
pour l'instant on donne des lettres de
mission ni ce qu'ils font est la
solution
la rgpp sont nicolas sarkozy vous avez
vu la difficulté qui a été très
difficile se saisissent les 15 milliards
on a fait quand même 15 milliards
d'économies en année pleine c'est vrai
qu'on aurait pu faire plus et que
c'était terminé
oui mais j'écoute et je souhaite qu'il
le fera que je souhaite qu'il le fera
mais vous permettre de dire au passage
aussi une rectification d'une opinion
qui est souvent exprimé par monsieur
ayrault et qui est totalement fausse
alors j'espère qu'il est mal informé
j'espère qu'il ne souhaite pas
désinformer l'opinion mais la rgpp n'a
pas du tout été une recherche
d'économies à l'aveuglette sans études
etc
et puis ce qu'il veut faire des audits
il en a plein ses tiroirs que nous lui
avons les gays
ça c'est dit 'tiens voilà
vous avez été au coeur du pouvoir à
l'elysée aux premières loges au
ministère de l'intérieur est ce que le
pouvoir vous manque
non c'est une autre vie et je dois dire
que c'est à certains égards satisfaisant
de vivre comme les français si vous
voulez mais bon je trouve que
fonctionnaire au ministre j'ai toujours
été assistée j'avais toujours un cabinet
des collaborateurs je suis seul avec
votre fils oui mais enfin on travaille
tous les deux tout seul ses volets
l'ordre que bon je prends des rendez
vous et tous et c'est très intéressant
oui l'or à sa première intervention lors
d'un colloque à new york qui a été
témoin nicolas sarkozy s'était lâché 1
république de banque et les rio mais je
vais vous le dire je suis un retraité
heureux vous laisserai jamais un
retraité volumineux l'on nous voulons
lui non plus d'ailleurs parce que si
j'en juge par ce conte activité qui fait
beaucoup de choses mais cela étant très
franchement pourquoi j'ai repris une
activité professionnelle parce que je ne
peux pas envisager de ne rien faire
voilà tout simplement je trouve que le
profession d'avocat c'est une belle
profession qui est conforme à une
éthique professionnelle qui m'a toujours
guidé dans ma vie publique et donc c'est
avec plaisir que j'embrasse les deux
questions d'actualité pour finir à
l'émission voilà après depardieu gérard
lanvin qui flingue à tout va dans la
provence
aujourd'hui sur la gestion de la sphère
depardieu les 75% et critique hollande
il dit qu'il a honte de la france il
conseille ses enfants de partir on est
en pleine lutte des classes c'est trop
enfin votre expression est intéressante
monsieur hollande voulait réconcilier la
france avec elle même
ils voulaient apaiser après l'ère
sarkozy où paraît-il la population
française était énervé par ces
initiatives
je dirais que d'abord que des
initiatives il en fallait et il en faut
il en aurait fallu même plus
malheureusement on ne pouvait pas parce
qu'il ya la crise et c'est bon
et ce qu'il a fait ou son gouvernement
c'est d'opposer les français entre la
façon dont on a mis en cause les
entreprises les chefs d'entreprise la
fonction d'entrepreneurs la façon dont
on a accumulé les impôts sur ceux qui
gagnent de l'argent sur ceux qui
réussissent fort forcément décourage
moi je peux vous dire que dans le milieu
où je vis je vois plein de gens qui
quittent la france c'est pas des gens
richissime il ne quitte pas physiquement
mais il créé des filiales à londres à
bruxelles et l'assiette fiscale est en
train de se déplacer
je viendrai force de taxes et on a moins
de ressources merci merci merci
fulgurant merci pérenne merci à tous la
semaine prochaine c'est fleur pellerin
la ministre de l'économie numérique qui
nous ne sera notre invité des tas de
questions bien sûr autour des
fournisseurs d'accès internet de google
et ses attraits va très vite